face down in the bed he laying face down
in the bed years after a 4-month-old
baby dies at the hands of his daycare
owner the Georgia woman is sentenced to
decades Behind Bars this after security
camera video revealed multiple instances
where she physically abused other kids
what is she being arrested for being
arrested F murder and cruelty to
children in the second degree for the
first time we're seeing the woman's
arrest and the emergency response that
the day of the boy's death including the
heartbreaking video of his mother
rushing to the scene I've her go in the
ambulance with them Scottish right ma'am
get go in the ambulance right there
they're they're getting ready to go this
is Mom on February 3rd 2021 police in
Dunwoody Georgia just north of Atlanta
responded to an emergency call for an
infant that was found
unresponsive hey guys right here
breathing still CPR y all right body
camera video shows First Responders rush
to the scene where they perform CPR on
the boy down in the B laying face down
in the bed
clear stay clear of patience analyzing
heart no shock let's go let's go sure
emergency Medal Service is this y''s
child quickly investigators identified
the owner of the little lovey daycare
now 48-year-old Amanda Harris hickey
video captures hickey explains she runs
the at home daycare no this I have a
family home daycare this is one of my
clients okay have we contacted them yet
no I haven't called anyone or done
anything yet go ahead and call yeah go
ahead let's go and call them
investigators tell hickey to contact the
parents of the former 4mth old baby
identified as Charles or Charlie
cronmiller later hickey explains what
happened when she found the boy I put
him to bed on his back but his parents
say that he could roll over but I had
never seen it what time did you call 911
I can show you um I was quite panick
fucking flipped out so I I dialed it and
then I think I just kept hitting it and
then I think this was them calling you
me back video shows hickey tell officer
she put Charlie down on his back but
investigators later determined she'd
actually placed him on his stomach
against recommended guidelines for safe
sleeping does Charlie uh suffer from any
medical diagnosis that you know of
okay and I'm sure you've already talked
to other officers can you tell me kind
of what happened Charlie was having a a
normal day according to his normal
schedule he sched at 3:00
m a little like I had heard from him so
I just let sleep and about 3:40 I went
in and found un responsive on stff okay
I put him to sleep on his back
unresponsive I'm still in the process of
getting everyone out of bed this guy
still sitting here cuz um so this is the
bed that Charlie was in okay I'm just
going to take a quick overview of the
whole room real quick and then Sor
you're fine keep his face I guess is
probably the best thing to do I don't
know he's not going to be in it okay
there you
go so I laid Charlie on his back and I
found him in the
corner this
corner R here into this position here
was there a mat or is it the mat that's
the M he was laying
[Music]
on so you said you put him down at what
time um a little bit after 2:00 I
believe that would be his normal
schedule like 2 or 2:30 and then he
would typically
um he would have slept and then had a
bottle at 3 okay so you came down at
2:45
3:45 I mean obviously if I would have
known we were having an emergency I
wouldn't have let him sleep but I
thought he was just tired or still
sleeping his bottle was scheduled for
3:00 so I have his bottle on the counter
ready to go like waiting for him to wake
up so this is just a and uh you just
show me again like that's for the front
this is the back if you just show how
you laid him and then how you found him
let me take a
picture did you see that yeah I left it
open because it needs to be drained it
hadn't it's not draining through the
hose and the buckets full I was going to
let you know that all a picture CL yeah
fine just so no one thinks that was open
right no you're fine you don't have move
that's F right here is good the light a
better
okay show me how you placed them sure do
a picture and then show you how
you
ready and there was another child in
there so you put him down and picked one
up right
did so he was in there by himself he was
yes yes yes there was a
switch okay if you show me how
you at the same time other First
Responders brief fellow officers on the
situation six-year-old or not excuse me
6month old baby was put down for a nap
at this house by looks like inh home
caretakers came down hey Dylan what time
did they come down and find him uh right
before they called okay put came down to
check on the baby right before they
called found him face down in the bed
not breathing not conscious not alert uh
CPR in progress no shock advised on the
AED soon Charlie's mother Stephanie
cronmiller arrives on the scene
she Sprints toward the ambulance have
her go in the ambulance with them
Scottish right man' get go in the
ambulance right there they they getting
ready to go this is Mom we want to thank
Morgan and Morgan the largest injury law
firm in America for sponsoring this
video now before you say oh great
another Law Firm ad first of all how
dare you don't speak that way of Morgan
and Morgan and second you don't know
what makes them special Morgan and
Morgan has completely modernized the
personal injury claim process they make
it super super easy for you how you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents and you talk to your
whole legal Team all on your phone now
if you're injured at work this isn't
about suing your employer it's about
suing your employer's insurance company
which I got to tell you is a huge relief
because I love my boss and you know what
my boss loves me honestly it's sad not
everyone has our kind of relationship
it's no longer the days of back-to-back
meetings and consultations an attorney
is going to review your case with eight
clicks on your phone that's it now you
might be saying sounds pretty expensive
right well here's the kicker there's no
upfront fee no you only pay them if you
win so it's no wonder over three million
people call them every year so if you're
injured you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com law on crime or by
dialing pound law that's pound 529 on
your phone as First Responders Rush
Charlie to the hospital others begin the
early stages of the investigation they
examined the pack and play where Charlie
was found officials would later
determine hickey left the baby in that
pack and play unattended for two
hours as the investigation continues
authorities quickly realize the daycare
Center is equipped with cameras so I
noticed you have cameras they record
24/7 um I believe so yeah or is it just
motion that's a great question I'm not
positive okay that's okay would we be
able to access those I think so and get
the footage like the F like the families
don't it's not like plny that I share
with the family that's a CL no yeah I
understand mattress pad she said that
was the mattress pad but it looks like
it's there's no pad in there I know
that's what I said but she said that's
what he was sleeping on they're all like
that though
I didn't want to manipulate it so I
haven't touched it yet
but he was found face down in that
corner top left corner uh she put him
back and he she said he must have rolled
over but they do have a camera in here I
got right there like it's not is it
going to capture now I don't
know
[Applause]
see that
M the discoloration on the pad yeah I
see it man and then the discoloration on
the um actual uh the brown yeah as video
shows hickey willingly provides the
security camera video to
officers okay I was just thinking see
what was
coming go ahead and get the the child
out I'm just going to keep looking
through for a minute if that's okay and
I'll be here when you come come back I'm
not going
[Music]
anywhere during this same time frame
hickey is seen crying when she faces the
realization that she'll have to speak
with the parents of the children she
cares for I don't know what to tell them
either but just tell them a baby had an
emergency I can I can escort you out
when you drop the babies off they have
any questions they I can answer those
can do that for you to help going be
really hard for you to talk really
hard baby had a medical you didn't
nothing what I just don't know I don't I
don't know
what I just yes I'll just need I'll just
need an escort just give them so you
hear me give them the same message to
everybody I'm not sure what that message
is yet but I need to tell them all
something we had an emergency what do I
tell them we had an emergency here today
and and I'm going to be closed to like I
my clothes I
don't I mean as of right now this is
just a um I mean it's all under
investigation we we have to figure out
kind of a few more things before we can
classify it one way or the other
okay I don't see any signs of malicious
intent here this we're not leaning
towards that by no means um but I can't
here and tell you that without a doubt
no I I don't you can't predict the
future I understand that I just don't
know what to tell them to tell them that
you know that you had an emergency a
child had to be rushed to the hospital
and leave it at that technically you
can't share any more information on that
right there so know that's all you got
to tell them y just tell them and if
they have questions um our officers here
we'll be glad to to help out
and this is
happen God the video also captures
hickey's husband comforting her as the
investigation
continues meanwhile emergency responders
take Charlie and his mother to the
hospital this is Mom right here okay
where can I go yes just coming okay
soon officials on the original scene get
word of Charlie's condition do we have
an update on the hospital yet yeah
they've given him they've given him a
bunch of rounds of e but it's looking
like it's yeah there's there's no signs
life
yeah I'll let y'all know here in a
minute but I expect here soon I'm going
get the official work doctors with the
parents they done about six rounds of
epine M sorry and um it's not officially
called yet but they're talking with the
parents and uh it looks like there's no
signs Al life so since he gives me the
final official word I'll let you know
Charlie was later pronounced dead
medical examiner will do an examination
on Charlie tomorrow to try to determine
what happened what what the cause of
manner of death
is that he may know that information
tomorrow that information may take weeks
depending on different tests that they
have to run and things like that so I
can't guarantee you that that
information will be available tomorrow
but once the case is completed and that
means once the medical examiner
completes their examination they get the
findings they have to write it up um
then I also have to turn in my
investigative report and the whole file
has to be approved by a supervisor so
there's kind of a chain of events sure
um but once that's complete you can get
a copy of the autopsy report if you
would like it uh I simply requesting
First Responders later speak with
Charlie's parents who have returned back
to the scene hi sir I'm not going to
hold you here for right now I am
detective Taffer I work with the Dy
police okay I'm going to go ahead and
let y'all go
home um I got some phone numbers for
y'all let me make sure they're correct
cuz I will be coming over later or at
least following up with you video then
shows hickey's daughter hysterical as
she arrives back home her mother says
there was a quote medical emergency mom
she in trouble your mom is strong is she
in trouble not right now your mom you
can go talk to your mom feel free feel
free had a medical
emergency in
trouble mom's not in trouble to worry
about you're going to
do can't had a medical emergency
as the evening winds down officers speak
with hickey and her family saying they
don't suspect any wrongdoing I haven't
found anything today that leads towards
any type of malicious intent you know I
can say that as of right now and I don't
foresee that on this but days later all
that changes when hickey is arrested at
her
home
hey M
Amanda
oh can you step out here for just a
minute
please
okay I don't you turn around face me put
change on your back okay you being
placed under arrest okay okay do you
want to talk to
me if so we can go back to the police
department we can talk if not you're
going to go straight to the cab jail yes
you do want to talk to me yes okay so
then we'll go back and we'll discuss it
at the interview room and then from
there you'll be released to the jail
okay okay can I tell anyone inside that
that's where I'm going who's in there my
daughter yeah give me call her down to
the door sure her name Natalie
Natalie Miss
Natalie can you come here for a moment
please going to go with us okay to the
headquarters for right now she wants to
talk to me and then from there she'll be
turned over to the cab county jail once
she gets to the jail she'll be able to
make phone calls and call and let you
know about bonding and things like that
but it's probably going to be a couple
of days before she gets a bond okay
okay so she wanted to let you
know
before she's taken away hickey's husband
asks the authorities what she's been
charged with what just so I can tell our
attorney what is she being arrested for
being ARR murder and cruelty to children
in the second
degree she's then taken to the police
department can I go in by myself yeah
I'm going assist you just so you you
fall there you
go place this seat Bel on for
you
we probably need to stop I I didn't hear
you say felony I heard you say felony
murder and I I wasn't aware of that so I
probably need somebody else here so if
we need to go I understand so you don't
want to talk to me well I would love to
but I
don't that is um I think that's big and
I think I need someone else here does
that make sense yeah okay okay so might
as well just leave a cup some so I need
to go you need to transport me I
understand when hickey realizes her
charges she decides not to speak with
officers you had an opportunity to
decide on whether or not you want to
talk to me or
not I don't know what to do so I I guess
we should just move me along I think I
don't I don't know what the right thing
to do is so um
I don't I don't
know so you don't want to try to talk
and get some questions
answered I don't think so I don't think
it's going to change anything at this
point so she's then booked into the daal
county
jail
yours
what's your last
name h i
y were you the vehicle accident
today body camera video shows an officer
later speaking with the kids parents
describ in the incident this is my
demonstrator hey bud Murphy hey so I'm
just going to use this door as her
door excuse me so he was standing kind
of like this you know looking out the
window there so she comes up and then
and the Mr Grand was standing next to
him so she walks up and opens the door
right and his feet are hitting it
stopping the door for moment she does
that four times okay then you can tell
that she gets annoyed by that and that's
when she grabs him right one one arm on
each spins around okay and it's it's
open here so he doesn't get anything so
when he spins around she's not paying
attention she's still looking at the
door and then drops him so when he hits
the ground his feet come up up over his
head he kind of rolls up uh and his feet
move over to the side so that shows me a
couple things one it wasn't just a
gentle set down because his feet
continued to move in the direction that
he was last his momentum was going right
from the from that sling um the child's
parents tell officers they never
suspected any wrongdoing I have two kids
of my own and I wouldn't want them to be
handled that way uh has he ever I know
you said he's been normal but he got
tubes put in but that's you know yeah
has he ever come home with anything that
you can remember I know I asked that the
other day yeah no
um no okay yeah and you hav never had
any problems with the with Amanda no I
mean quite the
hickey was charged with second deegree
murder Reckless conduct and multiple
counts of Cruelty to Children she later
entered an alord plea to Second deegree
murder meaning she maintains her
innocence but accepts that there's
enough evidence to convict her of the
crime this month she was sentenced to 35
years in prison 30 of those years will
be spent Behind Bars and the remaining
five will be spent on probation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie